the word PTSD and TBI and all of these
things I did not I didn't know any of
them uh
it was through people that I got to meet
uh in the training field that were you
know Marines uh
seals uh Marisol guys those types of
people that started giving words to some
of the things that I felt which I didn't
really know you know uh we would treat
uh post-traumatic stress with alcohol
and vacation time yeah
[Music]
yeah when you see the bottom of it your
troubles are gone cured yeah immediately
that was if I was an alcoholic as well
as all the other stuff I was
I was drinking myself to sleep every
every third night uh
my marriage obviously was failing you
know it was
it wasn't easy for her you know she
she was Brave and she did what she could
and I I totally respect to understand
her process with it but
and when it's quiet that's when it hits
you that's what I think that's what a
lot of people experience when they come
back from a conflict Zone you know the
uh
everything that was life and death
everything that mattered all the noise
all the chaos all the people that are
around you that would die for you kill
for you you would kill for them
uh all these millions of dollars worth
of equipment and stuff like that you're
responsible for now are all gone and
it's just you uh walking into a Circle K
and buying three cans of Fosters to
drink yourself to sleep
yeah you write on your patreon
brilliantly
about BTSD about the cost of things
you've done and seen
quote when it's over
and we're far from that chaos and noise
of death being close and life being real
that is when some of us remember in the
quiet nights in a field in Tennessee
looking at fireflies walking through a
fair
holding hands with a lover asking you
what's wrong
and your kid's birthday party leave
early to avoid the ending of a
celebration
that is what the quiet means to some of
us
so that's speaking to that silence the
quiet
um how do you live with and Thrive with
this newly learned term of PTSD if
anything I would recommend people that
have any of these issues to go to places
where other people have
their issues so you can it's not a
competition but you get to see the scope
of problems in the world and you
sometimes feel kind of lucky as far as
your own
like it humbles you yeah it makes you
appreciate of all the different kinds of
struggles that people go through yeah I
mean I went through some portals yet but
there's some people there that went
through while they're more horrible yet
or stuff that I I don't think I could
have survived when I went through that
process of figuring things out you know
the first thing that glaringly pointed
out or stuck out to me was my inability
to
process things like that there was a big
pause button there a giant one
everything was on pause
my reeving not only my mom but my
brother
so I had a pause button on me so since I
was 13 basically
uh then I got to bury
many of my friends
inform their wives or girlfriends of
what happened
and that all again was paused because uh
he wasn't uh allowed to process
now I spent years without going on
vacation because I was a workaholic
and uh
I found at the core of my issues uh
alcohol
the giant pause button in the form of
alcohol basically I I'll drink my
problems away or specifically I would
it's like uh if you have a mess in your
house you just put a big tarp over it
you know to cover it up and alcohol it
was at for me
and it festered more and more as I
not only went through the process of
learning about pcsd going through
therapy but refusing to let that go you
know it's like going through therapy and
seeing what other people's problems were
and
I don't want to you know this is the
only thing I have I'm not you know I'm
not hurting anybody with it you know why
why am I why do I need to get rid of
that
uh by this point I was traveling across
the country and training people and uh
showing some of the experiences that I
had to other people speaking being on
podcasts and having conversations like
the one I'm having with you so speaking
to the skills that you've developed and
in a way basically reliving and
reopening a bunch of [ __ ] for myself
every time I do it
um so it was that was getting triggered
and the way I would manage that was I
would drink you know at the end of the
night after a weekend class somewhere
when I talk about the fireflies and a
field in Tennessee
it was a moment where I was forcing
myself to try and be sober and we did
this medical class out and uh
out in the hills in Tennessee a
beautiful green Place uh beautiful
family there that that hosted us
and it's the first time I ever saw
fireflies so I was like I thought I was
having a hallucinogenic experience when
I said why is there why are why is the
dust glowing you know is what I thought
a friend of mine
is a the veteran he's ran off to the
woods and grabbed one and brought it to
me and showed it to me it's like holy
[ __ ] what is that's a firefly
wow how do they glow I don't know and
he's crush it in his hand and say it's
gone
and I I you know brought me back
immediately to holy [ __ ] you know uh it
kind of like I was off somewhere and I
was back
and I had to go drink
I went through that process of like
going off it getting on it going off
getting off at my marriage
separate
and that was a
another end of the world aspect to
everything you know you know
I lost my mother I lost uh the job and
then the marriage failed
and it was on me
I
basically went somewhere and did a stock
of everything that was going on
and made a decision to stop drinking
yeah I had a had some bad relationships
after
and I just came to a place where I need
to stop drink he's gotten dope points so
low
it was a decision you arrived at by
yourself
was there some inspiration
or was this just the point is so low
lost so much it was the start of Cobin
so this is recent that's probably too
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna have two
years sober in December
so when you talk to Rogan the first time
you're still struggling with this demon
I was in and out of the car basically
what I would say you know I was in and
out of and then
trying to get rid of it
that must be a super stressful
experience talking to Joe Rogan the
first time do you drink that night
you remember the second time I was there
I would I went somewhere got [ __ ] faced
it was
it was stressful not not for any other
reason than I felt the responsibility to
the people that couldn't speak about it
so that's a pressure
it was a start of covet and things got
it started getting shut down and slowed
down
my dad got really sick and almost died
foreign
Jason Bourne level [ __ ] that is at my
brother's place we
he was in Mexico you know so we had to
bribe a guy to get us an oxygen tank and
I had to Jimmy Reagan a respirator and
it was it was it was it was some [ __ ]
but my dad was like
yeah he really survived it you know
everybody at the doctors were like say
goodbye
and the the my dad was like yeah say
goodbye to him you know
okay he does a gangster I got it
a tough guy he did some gangster [ __ ]
that day
but uh on my end I was being isolated
basically his covet is uh everybody's
slowing down no more classes no more
excuses to go out there and drink and no
more socializing so social drinking
turned into alone drinking more and more
and more
I bought a bottle of gin
because uh I was I was down in Mexico
taking care of my dad
and uh they closed down beer production
in Mexico
so beer went away
and beer was a way I kind of Managed IT
you know it's not powered alcohol it's
just beer so you know
but that went away so it was just hard
alcohol that was available down there
I uh
one night alone at the uh at the house
my dad's house I uh
I drank a bottle of gin a whole bottle
of chin
I almost died
and after that you know
some people started noticing that uh
that I was isolating more and more and
it was kind of eating away at me
I was in a relationship at that point
when I
I started seeing everything just kind of
fall apart around me
and
I I drank half of a glass of uh wine
and it made me sick to mind like
internally in my mind
and uh my kid
said uh to me and I don't know nobody
coached or nobody said anything to her
she was
pretty intuitive kid
said I don't drink anymore dad
I thought of nowhere in the middle of
the night
uh and I stopped
I stopped that and I stopped that night
I remember waking up at three in the
morning uh and taking a cooler that I
had and just dumping all the beers in it
and
chucking them in the garbage and with a
knife poking each of them to not you
know be tempted to go pack for them
and then the second day I went around
and started finding the hides that I had
because I had some you know hides
and uh
and then I went somewhere and blocked
myself in for
two weeks
uh I had the
the withdrawals uh
the clearest nightmares that I've ever
had in my life or
two three weeks
I went somewhere and I want to keep them
private but I went somewhere where
they offered a place for me and uh
when I asked him about it they it's a
community I gave them some money for
their school as a donation again like a
few a few thousand dollars
as yeah sure come you know you can you
can go through this process here coolest
black people the first thing they did
when I got there is they stood me up in
front of everybody to thank me for the
donation
and then told everybody that I was an
alcoholic and if anybody saw me drinking
I was to be kicked out of there
immediately
and uh I actually felt horrible
um so
that's that was where I started is that
Temptation still there
was a moment when it was
uh and
uh some uh therapy Circle
there's a there's a rodeo clown friend
of mine who his body's
his spine is basically fused together
you know type of guy
uh we've been friends and enemies and
friends again you know in during the art
therapy uh Circle uh sessions oh so like
there's an intimacy there yeah
um he didn't know anything about me
uh at One Time Warner was telling our
story he stood up and told his story
and then he heard mine and then he was
pissed off at me and didn't want to talk
to me for a while
and then later he told me that it was
because yeah he saw what I did with my
experience and how much of a difference
that he perceived that I was making with
it
and he felt uh jealous that he couldn't
do the same with his experience because
he was just a broken Vex rodeo clown
he told me
when I was going through the process
like yeah your internet celebrity person
you know you're known
uh aren't you worried about people
finding out that you're that you're
recovering drunk and I said yeah it's
[ __ ] scary as [ __ ] if people find out
that I am going through this process
it's scary that you know the critique
you know I already get a lot of [ __ ] for
being a ex-police officer in Mexico and
all that uh all the negativity that
comes from that
and he said don't be
you know that you can't pick pocket a
naked man so just get naked and what
does that mean write about it post it
online
you never know somebody somebody out
there might get inspired do their own
kind of process
so I started boasting
cowardly in a way because I wanted to
make other people keep me on the path
you know
but in other ways you know uh
desperation you know I don't I don't
want to drink anymore I don't want to go
back to that on that uh baths which I
know leads directly to a bad death
I'm not afraid of death I just want a
good one I don't want a bad one I think
that was going to lead me to a bad death
I start writing about it sharing it
online you know through my uh fever
dreams post and
just uh being humorous about it online
and
getting a lot of hate on one side you
know having a few people and companies
that I work with kind of step back and
seeing these guys have some issues to
having other people kind of make fun of
or make light of that uh
weakness portrayed us getting hate
getting criticism because here you are a
kind of narcotics police officer there's
now has a drinking problem so is that
like supposed to be what like flaws
revealed weakness uh or a perception of
alpha in the US I guess that some people
have you know you were supposed to be
strong and here you are I mean I'm not
I'm not Jocko will Nick I'm not David
Goggins you know I'll I'll I wake up at
10 in the morning sometimes and I'll
have corn flakes with my eight-year-old
you know
um I like days off I used to wake up at
3 30 in the morning every day to to
review what happened during the night
and then go off for a jog and then
the gym and just be ready to be able to
murder somebody with my hands if I had
to but that is I couldn't maintain that
during the whole process of getting out
of it now leaving alcohol
I remember just being honest with it and
just seeing the two sides of it you know
Joe told me never read the comments
section right which is a beautiful
it's a beautiful piece of advice but uh
they get to you sometimes when you talk
about some of these things openly and
some of the comments were positive and
I've been
seeing people comment sending me
messages and meeting people on the road
that are five months in
10 months some people that have been on
that uh
wagon for way longer than I have
and uh
there's it's what's cool when you meet
people that are super human or
perform and take an extreme ownership of
things and are just amazing people that
are you know thriving out there
that's inspirational I see some of these
people and I'm like holy [ __ ] I need to
figure out how to get to some symbols of
that but I'm not that you know I've been
through the ringer I [ __ ] up I shed
ton of times you know my nose is a
example of that and
a few missing teeth
but in a way I think all of that is
part of the process that not a lot of
people want to talk about you know
independently of the experience I got
down there and some of the things that I
show and talk about and some of the
advocacy I do related to women like her
that are you know trying to look for a
better life and trying to find their
missing kids
uh training people to not get into those
situations uh but also showcasing the
fact that people that go through some of
these processes have
a journey to go through you know uh
I just came into your studio with a
duffel bag straight from the airport and
I'm gonna leave uh early tomorrow
morning to somewhere else
I've been on the road for
almost I think five years Non-Stop
I go back to a specific place every week
to see my kid for two three days and
then I'm back out
you know you know some people like are
you running like are you worried this is
afraid about so no but I am you know on
this weird
path I guess trying to look for
something that I think of
been missing